well thank you I'm delighted to be with
you this morning I the son of one of my
former partners is here with us he was
just admitted to the GSB it'll be here
in the fall Camilo Justine Jana so I'm
delighted to have him and I see one of
my students here I don't think Stephanie
I see a couple of former students but
yeah yeah well welcome back yeah every
minute managing growing enterprise but
most of you are not people who I know as
students so I'll apologize for those who
are students if they've seen any of this
before I had to think this morning when
Scott mentioned Victoria's Secret what
we only have seven limited partners in
my private equity business and one of
them is a guy by the name of Marty trust
who's the owner of Victoria's Secret and
I asked him about that you know how do
you get in it why does he like the
business you know what is good about
being in that business besides the
obvious and he said well it's a good
business because most people wear
underwear most of the time so that may
say something about their culture I
don't know but if you think about Scott
what we're here this morning to talk
about is really this topic of
entrepreneurs and culture if you think
about what Scott said this morning what
do you think the culture is at Intuit
now you only heard the guy for a half an
hour you have a sense for what the
culture might be and into it or not is
it still really obscure what do you
think well just throw out some words
clearly an emphasis on customers right
listening to customers innovating around
customers need very open dialogue it
doesn't feel very hierarchical that's it
you think about this would be a culture
where the best idea wins you know there
are a lot of cultures where there's a
hierarchy there's a political sense you
know the top guy look at Scott is there
I mean remember Ross Perot at ETS Ross
you know was president then he wasn't
and they moved people around if you had
a career at ETS you might be EVP one
year and head of sales another and then
move to something else that the idea was
that where we have needs is where people
flow and so you have a sense that that
anything else about into it I think
those are a couple of goods yeah ideas
are celebrate this is a place about
ideas and it is this guy idea the best
idea when so there's clear cultural
signals aren't there so any event we're
gonna talk some about entrepreneurs and
culture and I think we would have had
more people comment we named it
entrepreneurs and ideas profits new
ventures risk how to get capital these
things are interesting to entrepreneurs
but entrepreneurs and culture that just
doesn't feel like that you know is
something that really go see other
entrepreneurs are all about ideas
startups raising capital at Center so
we'll see if we can talk about culture a
little bit we I did a similar thing a
couple of years ago and talked with a
group of entrepreneurs and one guy
raised his hand said we don't in our
company we don't need no culture he
didn't say no so we don't need a culture
in our our company is all about they we
don't care about culture and another guy
raised his hand and said you've got one
you have got a culture you know you
really create one by that kind of
attitude so let's start out with a
definition of what we mean by an
entrepreneur leader and what we mean by
culture this only take a second
entrepreneurs are people that execute
for results they have this owner/manager
mindset where they're responsible they
marshal resources that they don't
control and they do the heavy lifting
when stuff goes wrong when there's a
a real problem the entrepreneur is the
person that does the heavy lifting the
culture then that surrounds them is all
about values norms the connection
between words in action the HP way it's
sort of how do we do things around here
so it's the intersection of these two
that we want to go and I want you to
take a couple of minutes
I hope we're pair in twos or threes
whatever's comfortable and tell the
person that you can connect with what
the culture is in your organization if
your students here at the business
school describe the business school
culture and these this should be only
two or three or five as quickly as we
did with Scott we captured sort of what
into its culture was what is the culture
of your organization describe it to the
person next to you take about two
minutes to do this era
with
go get yourself we're just having
everybody pair up and talk for about two
minutes about what is their culture so
if the two of you are together you might
just you might just talk about
describing what the culture is of your
organization in a couple of sentences
you tell grab him and tell him that
but they exclude you
or unless that they exclude you okay
okay all right
okay okay
right is that Andy girl oh yeah yeah
well I've met him but we don't know each
other you know I don't sorry
okay how hard was that to do in a couple
of minutes easy about you know there was
easy pretty easy don't we have this
sense what you comment yeah yeah
sometimes we don't know exact and and
words mean different things to different
people and so you may not have fully
captured the other party's culture by
the words they said and sometimes we
don't have the words to describe it but
we all have this real sense of what what
is what is the way about the
organization what are we trying to
achieve culturally in the organization
that we belong to another comment
somewhere up here yeah
exactly if any of you ever been involved
in a merger how does it how did it work
they don't work they don't work I mean
80% of mergers fail and yet when you get
the CEOs together talking about their
culture this oh well we value that we
value that too our culture is all about
I'd it so is ours they will agree the
words will sync up and yet when you
merge the two cultures they almost
always clash so today what I want to do
is just talk about some ideas around
culture you know just get some feeling
for what are some of the the things to
think about it there are plenty of other
things we could talk about related to
this but today we've talked about all
we're going to about what culture is and
that it does matter I want to mention
this notion of gravitational pull
something about motivators and how that
impacts culture and then where are the
levers and I'll talk about six levers
there you could pick 20 levers if you go
into an enterprise that are trying to
figure how do I change the culture how
do I respond to the culture you know you
need to figure out what what do I pull
on so we'll talk about a few of minute
courage you to throw out some other ones
that you may find so about a year ago
Linda asked me to talk to a bunch of
entrepreneurs about what were the issues
that they were facing and these were the
things that were on their list so these
are actually from a survey that that
they filled out you know organizational
issues people issues working in various
constituency system Hut operations and
finding personal balance sounds like a
pretty normal entrepreneurial festival
if you look at that a lot of it is about
culture so entrepreneurs really have a
whole lot of worries about the issue of
culture one of the reasons that we have
a concern over code I don't know if any
of you have ready Chuck and Aziz who was
a professor at UCLA who wrote about the
decline you know he wrote his book I
think was called corporate life cycles
you know why do companies
at various stages and these are the
stages that most of you are operating in
either infancy gogo adolescence or prime
as he describes it the most common
causes of failure relate in part to
culture you know this issue of conflict
over values and norms over not
developing a culture they also have to
deal with the founder it's interesting
in Scotts presentation that they've
dealt with the founder by moving him
into an area that he's really good at
and really interested in without losing
the funder a lot of organizations have
to lose the phone so these are common
issues but culture is one of the top few
how much can a leader influence culture
a lot they set the tone defines the
culture so 100 percent to start with yes
what happens over time what's that
he has to live the culture and if he
does live the culture then he has an
influence yeah
they will determine the culture so he
may at the very beginning and I think
actually the way it sort of looks is
something like this that in the
beginning when you're small the leader
has a huge you I mean most enterprises
may only be made up of the entrepreneur
at the very beginning with an idea he is
the culture you start adding people and
they're often very like-minded people so
they're very much together so it starts
to decline over time as you add people
and then I think there's a point at
which it either just continues to the
leaders influence on the culture
continues to decline or it actually can
increase you know because they're more
like my buddy makes certain decisions
and take certain actions that reinforce
his influence over the culture so we're
going to talk about this point and where
the levers are at that point a little
bit this issue of gravitational pull as
this idea of you know if you think about
masses bought planets you know the
leader has more mass at the beginning
and he really pulls people into the
culture at some point in time they're
influencing each other if the culture
gets away from the culture will actually
pull the leader into its orbit I'm not
going to spend any time on these next
one this question here does culture just
happened how many of you think culture
just happens in an organization it can
say more about that
you can have a culture of chaos a
culture of case of first impression the
culture of the most powerful winning me
cultures emerge those of you on the
other side of it make your case the
culture doesn't just happen
it was very much a function of how they
were their personalities and the way
they saw the world and they very early
on to find it and then they had the
blessing of I think it was Bill Lucci
here at Stanford or somebody studying
the HP culture in the HP way they
codified it wrote it down discussed it
had cases and it really became so here's
a culture that didn't just happen
it was a managed culture but if you
don't manage the culture it doesn't mean
you won't have a culture you still will
have a culture will be this either
emergent or directed thing and it's
pretty important as an entrepreneur so
you've given an example of a strong
culture HP it's actually a culture
that's probably in transit transition
now certainly one that experienced some
jolts other examples of strong cultures
either by types of organizations or a
specific organization you think of any
others Oracle has a very strong culture
and it and it's one that is very much
around a personality a very dominant
personality who's been able to exert his
influence through a lot of growth yeah
Walmart is another one probably starting
out with Sam Walton but then really
there was a whole management team that
went to develop that culture yeah
yeah and they're quite similar they're
quite similar other Apple Computer
yeah think different and to end again
it's around a personality Steve Jobs you
know can you think of some that aren't
around a personality Genentech okay GSB
clearly not around a personality staples
probably no longer originally Tom
stemberg had a pretty significant
influence but I think think of the
military military is a very strong
culture
I can almost spot you know we have a
half a dozen or a dozen military every
year at the GSB and I can almost spot
them not just by how they look but how
they're burying how they talk how they
relate to each other how they relate to
other students that Center it's a very
strong military culture so now I want to
get into kind of the meat of what we're
gonna talk about today but any of you
any pilots in here okay so you kind of
understand when you that's not daunting
to you you didn't raise your hand Lea
you're not a pilot what does that look
like to you
well I actually flew a simulator down in
Orlando jet I'm on the board at JetBlue
and they took our entire board down
there none of whom is a pilot and we and
they put us in these simulators and I
was sitting next I was in the the
right-hand seat next to Michael Lazarus
who is the chairman of Western Presidio
and he proceeded to crash the simulator
I was giving him all kinds of grief and
everything well they put me in the
left-hand seat and I was actually do it
because I'd had the chance to learn with
him so I was actually doing pretty well
on takeoff and kind of flying and
everything so the guy threw in fog and
you threw in you know winds and all
kinds of things and at that point in
time I crashed the plane as bad as
Michael did but that is a daunting
instrument panel I don't care who you
are even for you pilots that is a
daunting instrument panel well people go
into cultures and feel like oh my
gosh where are the dials what do I do
how can I influence the culture really
how can I fly this plane well as with
flying you know Camino when you fly
there really are only a half a dozen
dials you look at other things warn you
about things they're not unimportant but
there are half a dozen dials they look
at and they make all the difference and
you've got to be watching them and they
make they make flying possible where
something like that would be tough to
manage so I want to talk about these six
levers there are others but these are
ones that I've observed over the
companies that I've either run or served
on boards of or invested in and worked
with entrepreneurs on and will make
these make more sense but this is just a
quick note so first hire fire is one of
the places that you really influence
culture now people use hire fire as
shorthand you know well we hire people
and we fire people I want you to think
about hire fire in terms of a real
process and your culture will be
developed by how well you execute this
process if you really go through this
process in all of its steps then you can
develop the code you want at that point
where you're you're just declining and
declining an influence but you really
can't extend the influence that you have
as a leader or entrepreneur so it's not
just hire fire it's really the all the
things you do before hiring well what
exactly what you do to set expectations
at hiring and then how you follow up you
have somebody assigned as a coach do you
review and give 60 360 degree feedback
do you then decide to promote to
redirect or to fire on regular intervals
and how well you do that will have a
tremendous influence in fact there's
probably no more profound a statement of
what your culture is about then who you
hire and who you fire you know a lot of
organizations will accumulate Deadwood
you know rather than taking the hard
choice of letting somebody go
they'll reassign them somewhere and they
have piles of Deadwood although what
happens to a culture with piles of
Deadwood
yeah yeah I'll tell you I have a one
property where I've been stacking up
Deadwood and it's attracted rats I mean
they're rats are living in there and
that's what happens in a culture the
rats start to accumulate and you know
they make messes so you've really got to
do a good job of firing and a good job
of hiring I think that maybe want one of
your most important levers in setting
culture meetings are another one how
much of your day is spent in meetings
80% easy 80% you know if you define a
meeting as a conversation a telephone
you can have telephone meetings you have
informal meetings meetings by the
watercooler meetings at lunch whatever
but most of our day is spent in meetings
how well do we do at meeting management
you do great but how well does everybody
else do this is just a way to think
about meetings you know most meetings
are small and informal or large and more
formal there are a couple outside of
that that organizations have which of
the brainstorming ones to the employee
reviews but here's I'm going to give you
several quotes about meetings by fairly
well-known people
you recognize the names there's a lot of
fairly they were sat through a lot of
meetings how would you like to what
would think what would the cultural norm
be of an enterprise made up of these
people around meetings do you think with
that fewer meetings make them effective
make them decision making probably be
one around not having you know people
going off and doing their own thing I
mean a lot of these people are thinkers
or you know robust leaders they don't
want to meet with subordinates I mean
it's not necessarily a healthy view
about meetings you can just tell what
the culture would be if you had a lot of
people like that if you had a lot of
those people in the same organization
you'd have a hard time running it you
know yeah
meetings of CEOs can be brutal who gets
to stand at the podium who gets to
direct I mean it can really be tough so
learning how to do that so that's the
second thing so hiring and firing how
you manage time around meetings how well
you do that we could spend time talking
about each of these and how you do them
well but we don't have time today the
third one is this kind of how do you how
do you manage in a crisis when words
have to turn into action when you're not
just talking about what are our values
what are our cultural norm what do we
believe in when you take Scott cook and
you throw them in front of an of a
hostile group of customers what happens
then that will tell you a lot about
culture so a couple of examples Shawn
was in class this time we had David
Neelam and come and talk to us well
JetBlue who's the founder of JetBlue
where the New York Times was all over
David Neelam and for having released
some information to not the Department
of Defense but somebody who was looking
at customer information they were all
over him and it would appeared on the
front page of the New York Times five
days in a row and finally he called The
Times
what you know what is going on they say
if you'll just fire the person that made
the decision to release this information
to the New York Times it'll go away
because we'll have a scapegoat we can
blame it on somebody in the store you'll
disappear so David thought well that may
be a pretty easy way to handle it
however I didn't make the decision but I
would have made the same decision this
guy made and so I can't do that well
there was a time of crisis you know
where he could have behaved in the way
that would have been really easy to get
rid of the crisis but he Haven he
behaved in a way consistent with the
values of JetBlue and consequently that
story helped reinforce a culture of
personal responsibility of people making
driving decision-making down of standing
up for each other etc I talked a while
back to a group of foundation leaders
about the power of setting simple
straightforward goals and I gave us an
example Pepsi's goal which was to beat
Koch you know if you if you describe
what Pepsi's Koch goal was as a beat
Koch and it was that for 15 years and
everybody at Pepsi knew it well the
person came up after the discussion and
said I just want you to know that I have
a brother who was a warehouseman at at
Pepsi and we had a barbecue a family
barbecue for a holiday fourth of July we
had everybody over it was 50 people or
something like that and we had Koch
products he got back in his fan drove
down to the warehouse and brought Pepsi
products three places it was so deeply
ingrained in him so there was a culture
there there was a beat coke culture that
went all the way down then the last
example I'll give you of sort of
translating words and actions we had at
when I was at Trammell Crowe company we
had a sort of a health get you know we
were really pressing health preventive
health you know people stay in shape
run working prepare for triathlons do
all these things you know and and a part
of it was to lower health costs and it
was you know make your life better
etcetera well this worked across a whole
lot of the organization but in one of
our offices we had a guy that was way
overweight there was a heavy
chain-smoker well that's okay people
make their own decisions but the
interesting thing was that what happened
was his entire office you know nobody in
the office really got in very good shape
or stop smoking or whatever that it's
it's really and he gave the same talk he
gave the same speech because we were we
said okay we want you to talk about
health here's the here's the drill
here's our new insurance policy here's
everything he gave the talk exactly as
people and the other offices but it took
it had no effect because the words were
not translated into action so I think
having that connection between what you
say and what you do will be a culture
determinant so hire fire meetings how
you behave in a crisis the fourth one
and I apologize to my students because
they've seen this chart more than they
want to what is this idea of a lining
how do you align your organization so
that all the way from the dashboard that
you look at your flash report that says
okay here are the things for me these
are the drivers of our business works
its way all the way up to be consistent
with value so I would guess that on
Scott's desk for example if they're
really customer focused he will have
some kind of what was he what did he
call that thing a sort of the the
promotional you know the Net Promoter
Score I would bet that part of the flash
report would be a sort of a Net Promoter
Score and he would get that and look at
the Net Promoter Score and that would
drive it all the way up to our values
are really what are our customers saying
what they recommend us to somebody else
and and if you drives all the way down
through this then you've got a culture
that's likely to be self reinforcing
that's likely to have legs beyond what
the entrepreneur is saying or doing so
I've I've highlighted objective because
I think that's the easiest place for
those of you who are entrepreneurs or
her leading companies to start think
about what is winning what would winning
be and define it in a way that's
compelling and exciting then make sure
it ties in to your values make sure your
strategy connects with it make sure all
the tactic
connect and then make sure that your
dashboard is measuring the drivers if
you'll get those things all in alignment
you'll find that your culture takes on a
robustness takes on an energy it has a
life of its own if they are out of line
if any of those is not connected you'll
find that there are leaks in the culture
and cynicism actually develops one of
the reasons that people have a hard time
with this is these words can even give
definitions clear separating definitions
you've seen all these terms they're just
in alphabetical order these are words
that when they're when people are
talking top-level about things that
managers should think about they talk
about these kinds of things don't they
kind of give you a headache I mean I
just get really tired when I see all
this stuff I just I've heard this before
what's the difference between a mission
and a legacy and Abbey Hague and you
know you get confused I'm gonna try to
simplify this and just say you know I'm
gonna put it in three levels and say
really there are only three things you
need to worry about and have you think
about it this way in terms of a mountain
that you're climbing you've got a peak
you're trying to climb you want to
summit you know and the summit is either
the vision the mission your legacy
whatever is out there that's the peak
then you've got all these goals along
with it's all those mid-level things
that you said and then finally the
values and the values tied tightly into
your culture and if you don't get the
base right this is where you're
provisioning the climb as it were if you
don't provision the climb with clear
values with norms that people buy into
if you don't do the higher fire run your
meetings make sure you're aligned at
this base value you're not going to be
achieving the milestones you're not
going to get to base camp the camp one
and two three and four all the way up so
that you'll finally will summit so this
idea of the values being at the base I
think you can kind of lump all these
sets into a picture like that that makes
it a little simpler so think top level
the kind of intermediate level and then
this ground level so the fourth the
fifth thing then is kind of trust levels
the importance of trust if any of you
has anybody worked in an organization
with low trust yeah what's it like
and how do you how do you feel going to
work there yeah you want out
talent leaves what else happens in low
trust environments you don't like going
to work there a lot of time spent on
irrelevant things good people leave is
this a confession or a cheat was a
student - a few years back so I give
hard time I don't want the rest of you
to feel nervous they do this with my
former students though I give my hard
time
you know people have preconceived
notions they start collecting the
evidence to prove what it is they
already believe requisitioning their
supplies or whatever so you basically
you lose focus market focus probably a
lot of blame some guilt goes on with
that you lose good people yeah
productivity goes down I mean the value
if you think about the value of an
editor of a local trust enterprise goes
down that's it's a hard thing to measure
how do we measure trust but the value of
low trust environment are very costly
I've been in some low trust legal
agreements and if you're in a low trust
legal agreement what you do is you go to
your lawyer say what does this mean what
is section 7.3 a double I mean is there
something in it for me and then I go and
I try to say guess what this section
means and we tussled all this in high
trust legal agreements what happens by
contrast you don't read them you never
go back to the legal agreement because
you've developed a relationship you
understand that your job is to make this
thing work for both parties and the
parties work together so it's the same
kind of thing in a high trust
organization people make it work in low
trust organizations they look for refuge
they look to blame and they seek
political cover they do all kinds of
things so you really if you think about
the value of what you're creating if
you're doing it in a low trust way
you've diminished value dramatically
you know that's a hard thing to say
because I I would not say that you can't
repair trust I would just say that it is
really really tough it's one of the
toughest things if you've been betrayed
but if Trust has been violated my view
is get on with life in a different
format you know repairing that trust
well I think in theory it's a good thing
it's a noble thing try in most Kate and
I think you can find out if it's a
misunderstanding
a lot of breaches of trust are
misunderstandings so I think that's
that's the very first thing you do is
you go the person you say ok here's what
I'm saying here let's talk about this
and it may be that it's strictly that
you've misinterpreted something if there
is I'm talking about a real breach of
trust a real betrayal a real violation I
would say as a practical matter the best
thing to do is move on one of the other
of you move on I've tried in a number of
guides and personal scars remember ldj
that in I remember I'm probably the only
one in the room old enough to remember a
picture in Life magazine during well you
know you could remember you know yeah
but there's this picture of LBJ in
during the Vietnam War where he'd had
some kind of an operation and he lifted
up his shirt and there's this big old
body scar there and this big fat tummy
and I feel like LBJ when it comes to
some of these issues I can show you my
scars on various places for having tried
to do that so in theory I think it's
good to try in practice I think
violations of trust are some of the most
serious things
exactly how do you how do you restore
trust how do you rebuild trust as a very
yeah it's a very long slow tedious
difficult process which says to you
something about yourself is your your
personal promise is your brand
you're carrying it around every day what
you say and what you do if they don't
connect you have an implicit breach of
trust because people will interpret that
and that's your Brent you're spending
your brand so it's a really valuable
personal commodity that you have so
think about about maybe as people once a
person says I will not trust you anymore
it's very do and you are a cancer to
most cultures then so it's a really it's
something to to regard as precious yep
I think it happens at both levels but I
think senior management has a whole lot
to do with it you know if they say one
thing and do another what happens is
cynicism develops it may not be this
kind of personal breach of trust where
people have to leave for reasons of
Honor and you know being able to live
with themselves but if you say one thing
and do another as a senior manager
everybody in the organization develops
the cynicism
I saw talked the other day - and I won't
I'll obscure this enough that you won't
recognize it was but I talked there
today that was this impassioned plea to
a group of really important employees
about a certain issue and I have people
didn't know that I was hanging around or
who I was and so I overheard the
conversations afterwards the
conversations afterwards were completely
contrary to what this fellow had just
said and I thought watch the trust level
go down in this organization because
that's what happens
yeah
you know you wouldn't think that I mean
you go to business school to learn how
to model and to learn you know capex and
budgeting and you know all these skills
and it comes down to trust
you know what didn't you learn that your
mother's knee you know but a whole lot
of the things that are really most
important for an entrepreneur in
developing a great company are things we
learned at our mother's knees
well actually what happens when somebody
says I don't know
do you trust unless you trust him more
almost always what somebody says you
know I just don't know the answer I
figured a leader who's supposed to know
everything says you know I don't know
that I have to find that out your your
trust in him your belief in him or her
increases doesn't decrease so there's a
kind of a humility and a vulnerability
that will go to building trust well I
want to talk about these motivators here
and how they connect to trust many many
many years ago a non scientific non
researched book came out that talked
about these motivators that there are
five primary motivators that we all do
things for one of these five reasons and
I've tried forever to think about
various other reasons ideally I can
always cram them into one of these
categories and I think there's a
hierarchy that starts with force we can
make people in our organization we can
have a culture of force
we've probably needs to be a prison or
you know Sunday but you could have that
or you can have one of fear I actually
have I know some organizations that are
run by fear they're people are just
afraid and it's an effective motivator
for how long not very long it's only as
long as you're there you know like this
then it's effective the minute you turn
your back this guy's off doing something
else or whatever reward many many
business organizations are run by reward
then you get to duty and then finally
it'll up when you get up to the upper
end of these motivators there's there
are legs things continue to happen you
can step out as the leader and the trust
levels are so high that people continue
to build the culture the way that you
would you would build it so if you think
about business you've heard that
businesses operate on fear and greed you
know I think that's exactly how they
describe Wall Street in any event if you
think about families you know we think
well that's a lot more related to duty
11 you think about the longevity of the
relationships in the family you think
about the willingness of people to
sacrifice you think about the
the family cultures and that you can
kind of see that so the trust level by
organizations I think if you sort of
look that way and and if you can build a
culture that is more motivated by this
sense of duty and love where people are
really pet you know Scott and his team
cares about the customer cares about
solving customer but what was what was
his tag line something like jotted it
down building making a difference it was
more than that it was keeping revolution
alive in people's lives or you know
something like that exactly it was
creating change in people's lives where
they can't imagine going back you know
finally values and budgets you know it's
another way that you really can
determine a culture I've made this
statement around here for several years
that one of the most important if not
the most important value statement in a
company is its budget now what do we
think of when you think of a bell you
statement what do you think of integral
we believe in integrity you know we're
all about honesty we're about and naming
the virtue it's a kind of a name the
virtue kind of thing when you think of a
budget what do you think about
yeah follow the money you know cutting
budget holding the budget your budget so
how do you how do i how do I connect
values with budget how was a valid that
was a budget a value statement that will
impact culture how is it one of the
levers what do you mean by that
okay
you have an R&D budget if you value the
sales effort you may have a budget on
bonuses the salespeople if you value new
business there may be recognition in the
budget for creating new but you may have
a new biz dev a big business yeah so
whatever it is Stephanie you have a
comment or you just exactly the budget
is where you make the bright line
decisions if you already think about the
rest of it of just words the rest of it
is just words it is in that budget and
if you can get your budget to feel that
way the or zation people will like it
better that doesn't mean that all the
decisions will be popular they'll be
debated but they're debated over values
and it's where you draw the bright line
it's not the difference between good and
bad that is a tough decision it's the
difference between good and better and
where you draw those lines is a is it a
culture determining an important thing
in the budget is a powerful document for
that
it is no it says everything about what
we what we value and what what our
elected officials think we value because
they're buying votes and we know what
they value you know because they are
buying votes that's what they value but
it's what they think we value and that's
where money gets allocated okay well
there's a great example and so what does
that what is our attitude towards
politicians we don't trust them we are
sitting and effect I think they are now
below used-car salesmen I mean I
actually think they are down there at
around 14 or 15 percent you know they're
the least trusted people and it's
because I mean it's one of the main
things is this disconnect if you if you
can print money
yeah
it's one of the things that you as as
entrepreneurs you know we have to make
payrolls there's something about having
to go out and sell enough you know
create a good get enough customers sell
it at a price where the customer is
saying this costs me less than its value
to me that's the decision every customer
is making is that this cost is and you
and the business are saying this cost me
less to produce then I can sell it so
that's a wonderful discipline that if
you're printing money and you can run
with deficits forever you don't have to
face like old consequently what happens
to the culture well that we could spend
the rest of the time talking about kind
of what's happened culturally in this
kind of environment but it's it's very
powerful culture is this underpinning
thing that will drive and it has a life
that lasts generations and it's true in
an entrepreneurial environment it's true
in that you know in the nation
Linda what when do we have to go ten
thirty okay what plenty of time for
discussion okay so since so those are
six levels so what so you can see a lot
of this about culture has to do with
your core values so what are your core
values yeah I did this and I think
several years ago and I I broke the
people into discussion little discussion
groups and one guy raised his hand after
this okay I've got my core values and he
went down through him and said number
one is number two is over SIG's and
number eight is or eight is can't
remember number eight what's the problem
with that
yeah he forgot the notion core you know
core means core you know you got to be
able to remember them or they're
probably not core so what are your core
values family okay could I could I
figure that out by following you around
okay honestly could I figure that out by
following you around quality and I would
figure that out by following you around
my thesis is that you're about you're
wearing your values on your sleeve all
day long that it is very clear if you
spent 24 hours or 48 hours
with somebody you can tell a lot about
their values because it's a function of
where they spend their time where they
spend their money and what they talk
about what's on their minds that those
really are your values no matter what
else you say maybe your values where you
spend your time money in mind share are
you in real values the same it's true
individually and it's true within an
enterprise and this is a big part of
culture you know where does the company
spend its time money and mind share what
does it talk about and you'll have a
sense if you if there's a how you doing
if you if you see a big disconnect there
you're gonna have a cynicism in the
culture I'm gonna give you a quick
example this and then just open it up to
discussion questions several years ago I
gave a talk to a group of ypl executives
and they I have seven children by the
way and I know what was I thinking I
wasn't
any event they've actually all turned
out really well
you know which is an even bigger
surprise but and I made the statement in
this you know prior thing that the
greatest thing that you can give your
children is high self esteem it's a
really important thing and so they asked
me to give a talk on how do you help
your children increase their self esteem
how do you help a child grow up with
high self esteem and so I thought you
know I'm going to put to the test this
notion of what you do what you spend
your time money and mindshare on and
what you say if those things are totally
connected the child will have high self
esteem because they'll see the parent
behaving in a way that is consistent
with what they talk about so I didn't
experiment with my children and I asked
him you know what do you see or what do
you hear your dad say in other words
what is my constant advice
what is the drumbeat that comes out of
me all the time so this is what they
they said you know you've said some of
these things to your own kids right
that's pretty that's kind of from the
standard manual of high-performance
parenting you know so this is what dad
said now what my thesis was that what my
next question was tell me what you've
seen me do now how do I live how do I
behave and I want you to draw the
conclusions about what is good right
important from what you observe I
thought there would be a really close
correlation here because I was building
these children with high self esteem so
here was their response
you know they say you can't fool kids
you know and that that describe to me I
took that seriously there's a real
problem you know you eat you eat
slim-fast than M&Ms you hypocrite
you love mom except when she's late so
here's the problem and this is a
cultural problem if the leader says
something in the leader does something
else it shows a lack of integrity
there's organizational cynicism that
builds up then there's this loss of
trust and the culture that line that we
showed where you're at the inflection
point where you can actually increase
influence in an organization's leader or
lose influence on the culture that
happens when this happens this is the
most important thing I think you do I
had a company this will I think be the
last slide and I would encourage each of
you to do a simple simple survey like
this which is basically have people
assess the trust level in your
organization one being no trust at all
and ten being you know I trust this
person with my life and I wouldn't look
the other way you know just kind of pick
a place along the continuum where you'd
say this is the trust level in our
culture and then write down what our
three top goals are and write down what
our core values are and the three
critical core values this organization I
did it with ended up at about a four and
a half and a five and a half they were
stunned and then we looked at what the
goals were no two people had the same
goals by the way the Franklin Covey
organization does surveys they've got
like 60,000 of these in now and they
find that less than 20% of all people in
well-run companies know what the goals
are is that a staggering I think they
could articulate the
worse than that very few people even
when they do know have a line of sight
that means they know what it is they do
and how it impacts the achievement of
those goals and high performance
organization high performance cultures
can name the three goals and each person
can say what I here's what I do and how
it impacts the achievement of these
three goals
same thing with core values the core
values were all over the map
consequently they got kind of a meddling
range I think you can short the stock of
people all over the long haul it doesn't
mean necessary in the ShoreTel but you
can short the stock of people where the
trust levels because of Uncle lack of
clarity around goals and around core
values you're really not going to have a
culture that will sustain itself beyond
the life of maybe the CEO that's there
or beyond the life of a great product or
beyond the life of a unique competitive
advantage I mean all those things really
have some market legs but they die most
organizations don't last you know if you
really think about it they're very few
that last you know
okay well let's any comments questions
reflections on any of this you get out
early Linda that's all I have prepared
yeah
what's interesting when you say the
day-to-day needs to survive that is a
value you know that's a value and and so
I think you I think articulating clear
wedded it clearly what it is we're about
is time well spent I think for people to
jump up into the clouds and start
talking about legacy when they can't
meet their bills you know I think it's
misplaced but don't kid yourself that
you've got a you've got a set of values
I remember a consultant coming in to
work with me one time when I was running
a company said you know this
organization doesn't care about profits
I said well our values are this that and
the others that profits are a value you
know profits are a value and you don't
care about bro and in point of fact we
didn't we were all about building new
space we were all about how many
billions of dollars in new construction
starts do we have we were all about you
know building personal networks but we
were not about current period profits
that was not a value for us and it was
kind of shocking because I went it and
did the accounting I checked it out we
were losing about twenty five million
dollars a year and our current period we
would finance then we and expand we
covered it up in everybody but one of
our values was not making profits so I
think just being real talking really but
what is it you really carry a real value
is survival what do we need to do to
survive we want to survive because
that's what's gonna occupy occupy your
time your money and your mind share so
be real when you're talking about values
be real don't just claim high-sounding
virtues or you'll develop cynicism
so I'd say wherever you are those are
your values articulate them be clear
about them they may be values on their
way to something else but I'd say be
really clear about what they are yeah
it's a different kind of culture that
you build it's around a task it's around
a deliverable and you can have an
expectation that these are our value
this is what we deliver to the customer
this isn't an exact analog but at
JetBlue we've got res associate
reservation who are all in one city and
2,000 miles away or is our operation and
so we don't see those people very much
but their whole culture is about being
pleasant solving customers problems and
something I mean there's like three
things that they're major
and they're all they talk about are
those to you what they're measured on
what their bonuses are are all around so
there's a culture around it deliverable
I'm not sure there is a you know that
there really is an enterprise culture or
even the possibility to do as much of
that don't like your culture and they're
clear that that's the culture they won't
get hired nine times out of ten and so
you can actually whether you're
front end screen and they'll self select
a lot absolutely yeah you know we we do
buy for culture you know it matters to
people and we have this gut sense well
you know any of you read this book blink
you know since the idea of thin slicing
you know where we make there was a study
done
I think it's mentioned in the book I
don't recall done I think it was at
Harvard where they had a professor teach
for 20 minutes and then they had
students rank him and then they had him
teach for 20 seconds and they had
teach for 10 seconds with no sound and
had students rank them and there was no
difference it just says content doesn't
matter I guess but I think what it's I
think what it really says is we assess
very quickly and fairly accurately what
it is we like and relate to and there
are all kinds of nonverbal cues and
everything with cultures a little bit
the same way there's a lot about culture
that is in the air its ambient we pick
it up people are sensitized to it and so
people with options will opt for
cultures that share their values so it
is kind of a mutual buy-in so that may
be a partial answer yeah
and so and so although they understand
Monday
I'll give you one example it may
generate other examples I think rather
than just say you've got to care more
about customers you've got to reply
reply in 24 hour you've got to do the
seven yeah another way that's one way to
try to just and it's basically the
sledgehammer approach because they just
keep beating them up until finally in a
bloody pulp they do as close as they can
to do another way and I'll give an
example on this is we had a had a
partner in Austin Texas that built a
building that we couldn't lease that's a
problem when you're as you know real
estate is a highly leveraged business
and if you got a lot of debt and debt
pay when you can't least the done well
he figured out that the very best
customer for this building was ETS and
the DDS should probably buy the building
he talked to the EDS manager in Austin
and he said now we don't have any
interest so he called up to Ross Perot's
office and he figured out who
rosboroughs assistant was figured out a
way in to talk with her enough to know
what his schedule was found that he was
on a trip to New York traveling in C to
D and so he booked to see and he had
Ross Perot for two and a half hours and
that two and a half hours east made a
sale of the building to rustboro well
that's not as amazing as the value of
the story this story has been told over
and over probably with embellishment but
it is now part of the culture it is now
part of the mythology and that mythology
then says our culture is one that sorts
out problem we figure out the creative
solution we do whatever it takes to
score the touchdown we and and so
there's a whole lot of thing and that
way setting that bar up there finding
people who do achieve beyond what we
expect I think is a much more likely to
succeed way of getting everybody to come
along than just beating people up when
they're not doing what it is you
and typically when there's a lot of
celebration around let's say the wrong
the right people will leave you know
because they'll just say I can't meet
that standard
- action I have to show and so I
separated
and show them how how was done for the
first month I happens it every day and
work with the children but then this
became part of their
you know that's that's part of the
mentor and the power of mentoring which
a lot of times people think the clients
that idea of it declines over time the
power of mentoring I actually think
there is an inflection point in that too
where the story of what the CEO does
gets around in a way that is embellished
you know and it really helps so you can
actually do a few things as a CEO and
word will get around I hate to go back
to JetBlue but it's it's a lot of what
I'm living right now and we have this
really unique founder whether David Neil
Elman who he'll come to the office and
sometimes he'll be done by 10:00 in the
morning with what it was urgent and
you'll say I'm gonna go out and catch
our flight to Orlando so we'll go out
and get on the plane fly down to Orlando
and back and during the flight he'll
make sure he talks with every single
customer
he'll deliver snacks you know he'll help
clean the plane well he doesn't need to
do that that many times and he's
extended the culture even in a 10,000
person organization and their stories of
him going out and shooting hoops with
the the maintenance technicians in
between flights coming in he'll just do
little things okay he'll load bags you
go out in fact we were at a board
meeting one time down in Long Beach and
the board is you know like a little herd
following each other around to the
various stations looking at things a
sudden we look up and there's no David
now we can't find the guy anywhere and
suddenly somebody spots him over at one
of the check-in counters and he notice
the lines were too long for people and
he wanted his expedite so he was
checking customers in there he'd left
the board now he also has ADHD so he's
pretty random but I mean the story of
that kind of thing
gets around and it extends the the the
brand extends the culture
plays culture from the middle
well there clearly are pods you know and
you can't have a lot of influence it's
very difficult that to overwhelm what
the leadership team is doing and
reinforcing Euler because they control
the first Springs
they control time they control budgets
they control we talk about me so you
typically get either cynicism or
conflict from that Evan that's not to
say you can't have a lot of influence
within a team and I've had that
experience where I've reset cultures
from within you know a level but what
how far up at migrates you know it kind
of depends
no it's a if it's a leader is bad I mean
look at I won't name names but I can we
probably all think of some of the same
names where would actually be better
with the influence of the leader
declined
don't let the culture take over Chuck
Phillips was brought into a organization
to head it up here in the Silicon Valley
that I think if he's able to get the
culture inculcated that he likes it will
actually rejuvenate this enterprise
one guy guts don't say that
yeah
you know I think that's probably an
expression of value saying we are a
multicultural business we're a global
business and there are other companies
that have hired CEOs from different
cultures most of them that I know of at
least have had enormous international
experience they've worked at a bunch
they I don't know this particular story
has he had a lot of
yeah
yeah so there'll be a lot of cultural
debris as they changed in their culture
and whether or not they successfully do
or not it'll be an interesting life it's
not to say that company's cultures don't
change they say sometimes evolve and
there's sometimes they change in
revolutionary ways you know an
interesting case was what was it Phipps
or Phillips Brothers that brought about
Salomon Brothers this is maybe 20 years
ago you know the big investment banking
firm was bought by Phillips Brothers and
they were two or three times the size of
Salomon Brothers within a year it was
all Salomon Brothers you know the
Salomon Brothers culture was so much
more sharp elbowed so much more powerful
so much more aggressive that they took
over so Phillips Brothers basically
disappeared even though they were the
acquirer
so it you never know in these culture
wars what's really going to happen
they have that
well you know again I what I do is I
look for the levers you know what are
the lair I I've mentioned six of them
that I think are your most powerful
levers they're the ones that will turn
the plane the most and the quickest they
may not be the right ones it's just like
when you take very strong evasive action
and a plane you may you know may snap a
wing or you may have prompted so you
really have to be careful those those
are the powerful level levers but I put
number one as higher fire I mean if I
want to chant there there are some
important and I won't won't bore you
with my own history but I there's a
couple of firings I've made a very top
level people you know and there's
nothing that says change and seriousness
and culture and whatever then firing a
key person I'm not here to celebrate the
idea to just go in and shoot people but
I really do think that if there is a
cultural clash if somebody is going in a
direction that you cannot go to let them
go is a powerful statement and when you
need to think about it buddy that's
probably the number one
let's talk after about the specific
circumstance because I'm not sure I can
generalize it in a way it would be
valuable for any one last question and
then we'll know there's one way back
here that's been hiding
be careful about when your schedule
people can dial in by conference call
training people on how to run efficient
some meetings so that they're useful in
that big waste of time money to bring
people having to work together a lot
together in one place and a fairly
celebratory sort of setting so that they
can get to know it
and if you're gonna value that with the
increase in your personal change you
need yeah that's right I think there are
a couple of things in there that I would
just wrap up with one is the importance
of celebration because there are very
few cultures that are healthy that don't
celebrate there's something powerful
about celebrating wins even if the winds
are we're losing less than we did last
war you have to celebrate wins and the
second one is that this there is a truth
in this idea of organizational entropy
you know the second law of
thermodynamics that left to its own
things will start to fall apart you know
and if you don't invest into and
particularly the more far-flung the more
you have to think about it doesn't
necessarily need to be a lot more money
but you really have to think about it
and get high leverage and invest energy
and time and some money if you're gonna
maintain the culture yeah I think it is
more often than not